hey guys it's Dennis the founder thick
here and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is a review for agents of shield episode
13 tracks with the periods between yeah
I'm so you know along with you know our
review of almost human which I said was
like the best episode so far I think
this was the best episode of agents of
shield so far yeah and I I like it
because it kind of does all the stuff
that I fixes all the problem not all the
problems but some of the problems that
we were talking about I mean now it's a
storyline with with characters that
they've talked about in the past and
they built up it's not an episodic thing
yeah also I felt like there was actually
real danger for the characters and
actually found some of the dialogue to
be humorous yeah I mean there were some
good moments you know you know you said
this is one of your favorites and I
heard was like you know the best episode
of the season there are some good
moments uh was i seen Mike again I'm
glad Mike spec you know I'll get that
some that all stuff in the end but it
was a little better if anything to show
me that mania ancient may needs her own
TV series she's just go lone agent I
would watch that it's all week I like
that cuz the one thing I did like they
developed its last my guess four or five
episodes is a her relationship with
agent what's a so much for more the
agent ward and I like they kind of
wanted a little bit more the complexity
about that she's so hard and cold
sometimes but in words like you knows
okay let me go with you know i'll try
and like be you and everything so i like
i like some of the ones in here still I
there was danger I don't know if I cared
about the danger though and again this
is for me not caring about the carrying
your loss I think I think I'm done I'm
done I'm glad does cuz all of you guys
been getting on us about you know why
even review the show you look happy look
I'm smiling I'm energetic right now I
don't like the episode but I'm energetic
about it and happy um but it's good to
hear that I'm glad that you you enjoy
this episode now we we are some the time
yeah well I'm hoping it's a turning
point right I hope that I mean I've said
that before and other episodes but I do
think this is the strongest episode so
far yeah I think they've built on some
of
stuff I think they just took their time
I mean really took their time episode
ends along yes to get to one good
episode right where where they've
they've taken some of the stuff in the
past like with the width of my character
and developed him and then this this was
like a million billionaire guy yeah
right that um sky was supposedly working
with or you know and all that I think
some of the relationships too I mean you
have mine war but you also have mine and
Coulson Yeltsin in sky sky may like
drama fits in sky like you can tell Fitz
has visit Simmons yeah it has an
attraction to to sky and Simmons has
attraction to war like that so I feel
like they have this episode was able to
build on that I also like that we got to
see the different perspectives now from
from all the different characters and
you know I just thought it was a
well-done episode not it's not a great
episode right right but it was good and
I think it was definitely the best one
they've had so we had to give the show a
credit this shirt this episode was
creative I guess we should probably just
segue into the the juicy parts of this
and that is the ending spoilers so we
may be getting Deathlok yeah looks like
you know they gotta compete with you
know seed of arrow has Deathstroke this
shows gonna have Deathlok you gotta
compete with it i am glad Mike's bacca
seen Mike made me happy you know I'm
glad that he's going to be a part so
because they spent so much time with him
in other episodes it's like look you
gotta go somewhere with a character
otherwise you're just wasting our time
right and so I think they finally I
think they already had that plan in
place I'm not saying that they they you
know just figured it out they had the
plan in place they just took a long time
to get there and I think that's the
thing they marvel has such a huge
universe it seems like the show has
almost been scared of grabbing from that
universe because of the Cinematic
Universe that you know just dominates
everything whereas you know arrow
doesn't really have that problem because
DC is just all over the place don't know
what the heck they're doing so arrow can
like hey let's take this person let's
take this person just throw them in
there and see what happens I feel like
with this episode with the whole
Deathlok scenario they're actually start
do that you're like hey we have all
these characters hate some these guys
one has to be in the movie let's put
death lock in our state and our story so
I hope they do more of that as the
senior so I just don't know why I don't
do weighted like so they waited too long
dillards it but just not for this year
is for a lot of series you know fringe
is a an awesome science fiction series
it took almost you know two-thirds of a
season estar to convince me to keep like
that I kinda gave up after the first
power success is like no keep going and
i did and i ended up loving oh I don't
know why there's this mentality in
especially in network television versus
a cable tell you have to get such high
ratings like why yeah but the thing is
they ultimately hurt their show yeah
because look at look at Asian cheese
shield now now okay let's say they
finally have it hypothetically this is
good episode right and they turn things
around and from now on these build on it
gets better after this all is gone like
you've acted on lost all these people
because you you put out crappy episodic
stuff before and this has happened time
and time again with other shows like
yeah I don't know why they have this
mentality of well we just got to make
sure that we build this episodic thing
and so that the causal viewer can watch
it and then you know they can get hooked
it's like no that doesn't hook people
who hooks people is overarching story
lines characters they can care about all
these things that they can build on if
they do it right from the beginning
think about shows that start right from
the beginning did Breaking Bad like go
oh let's make an episodic all right yeah
right i mean into it's like I think she
was worried again even with almost human
does this at times not as badly as
agents of shield but this play it's so
say yeah it's like you can be geeky I
like I was just out of curiosity I no
TVs change over the other DVR and
blu-ray and all but I mean I did some
research Star Trek The Next Generation
average 13 and a half million viewers
like that's crazy number i know people
kind of watch more shows back then but
still took thats a lot of numbers and
thank you like you can be geeky you can
have Borges and weird phasers and set to
stun and engage i mean you can be geeky
you don't have to like be safe in like a
trap people if it's good people will
watch a game of thrones is kind of weird
people love Game of Thrones it's a weird
[ __ ] if not episodic this is not
Epis I'd start right when the show
starts your life who's that what are
they doing I'd understand it up and then
by a few episodes you get into it I
number one and I never liked hearing I
know this is just how it works in the
industry it's like to like oh just wait
it's gonna get good i'm like why can't
it be good now why can't it be engaging
now like I want it good now unlike this
show like i said this episode I'll give
it credit it was better but yeah I don't
know maybe it's too late for me i don't
know i think so i might be too i think
your hardest it's hard I kind is it like
when I'm watching the summer sit there
like I do I refuse to watch this show I
thought there's funny dialogue between
Colton and Simmons right doing the whole
father-daughter how l simmons pretended
she had this whole backstory right
however their mother died or her mother
died and like you know I reckon accent
was funny when the exactly would you
meanest guy and uh yeah so I thought you
know it was definitely I think this
episode if this had been like I said
with almost human right you take this
episode you put it earlier on right
third fourth episode I might be into it
then exactly when we so mean and grumpy
about the show and I honestly think that
agents of shield like even if it keeps
on getting better that they've already
lost so much of their audience and
created this impression right of being a
bad show it's gonna be hard fun to get
that audience back I just don't know if
that's gonna have Hannah so you know
well hey how is another ages episode of
agents of shield yes so I'm looking a
little more forward to the next one that
I usually am and if they can build on
that then I can keep getting more
excited about it but let's see what
happened now continue to watch it each
week sitting down with the big you know
you know grumpy look on my face is
snarling uh I am trying to keep an open
mind and I did enjoy us episode more and
i have a few of the others so what do
you guys think let us know if like is it
too late for agents of shield did this
episode turn around for you or were you
already liking it anyways and what do
you think is going to happen in the
future you can post your comments on the
website think you're calm and on our
youtube channel think hero pro make sure
to subscribe to that i'm also going to
shout this on twitter took the dennis
michael myself in your all former or
current still still current common
readers so let us know like you know
what do you think of the come the comics
what could the show learn from the
comics what does it do embedded in the
comics is it secretly the best show on
television please let us know that at
think hero i'm at griffin de and we also
have a Facebook page that's facebook.com
slash think hero fans make sure you like
that page and share our videos on
Twitter and everything else
you